i think throughout my life i'd always
taken such
attention to
how others felt and
real is the best manifestation of my
life's work hoping to help
[Music]
i'm mariella safira i'm the founder and
ceo of riel and i am 27 years old
real is a mental healthcare company
really bringing a new therapy model to
life we're not simply putting one-on-one
care online rather we're taking 10 steps
back and asking what are the goals of a
mental health care system and how can we
bring that to life in a way that is
affordable for the entire country in a
way that actually works actually
improves our mental health and in a way
that people are actually proud to take
part in
i became passionate about mental health
care when i was an undergrad a sophomore
at stanford when a friend had attempted
to take her own life her experience in
rehab was the first time she had ever
encountered the mental health care
system
very immediately i thought
imagine a world where someone never
meets a primary care doctor until
they're diagnosed with cancer right this
system is failing us if people aren't
even meeting it until they reach rock
bottom
i thought the system didn't make sense
you know so i threw myself at it i got
in touch with david kelly who's the
founder of ido and we hit it off ended
up spending two to three years working
together and how can you redesign mental
health care at that point as i'd
mentioned the goal was
not to just get more people to
one-on-one care but rather how can this
be a part of our everyday of our family
systems of our conversations at dinner
much like you know we see fitnesses
i think being under 30 in mental
healthcare is one of my greatest
advantages
i think that healthcare
has not been
disrupted
and it is so hard to
envision a new version of an industry
when you've lived in it for years i get
to have such a fresh pair of eyes and to
envision a completely different future
[Music]